qué tal muy buenas noches pues lo cierto
es que estos son más de tres millones de
votantes que ya habían ejercido su
derecho al voto de manera anticipada y
representaban un poco más del 40 por
ciento de todo el electorado del estado
de georgia sin embargo la imagen del
conteo de incesante de votantes en todos
los centros de votación se ha visto en
georgia y es que muchos de estos
votantes decían que eran unas elecciones
decisivas y era más importante que nunca
que su voz es escuchada y no es para
menos porque el estado de georgia va a
acabar definiendo el futuro del senado
si los republicanos revalidan su
liderazgo en la cámara alta muy
probablemente la mayoría de las
propuestas y proyectos de ley que se
presenten tanto de la casa blanca como
del congreso acabarán bloqueados por eso
dicen que hay que aquí la gente dice que
su voz se ha de escuchar y por eso han
venido a lo largo de todo el día a
expresar su voz de las urnas
precisamente antonio estos comicios
llegan
extenso con ciudadanos muy divididos
cómo van las reacciones al momento y que
podría marcar la diferencia en estos
cerrados comicios
uno cuando está en los alrededores de
los centros de votación se da cuenta que
en la sociedad de georgia está
profundamente dividida unos creen que ya
hace falta un cambio de rumbo en el país
mientras que otros adoptan el discurso
de joe de donald trump diciendo que ha
habido un fraude electoral y que las
elecciones deberían ser mucho más
transparentes de hecho estamos en un
centro de votación donde la mayoría de
los electores son latinos y es
precisamente este segmento de población
que se ha fijado joe biden en las
minorías latinas ellos también
consideran que es hora de que se les
escuche y que se pueda tirar adelante
varios proyectos de ley entre ellos la
reforma migratoria que el propio bardem
había propuesto durante se había
comprometido durante la campaña
electoral y le dijo que si llegaba a la
casa blanca en los primeros 100 días iba
a proponer un proyecto de ley para
reformar esa ley migratoria para
y legalizar a los indocumentados en eeuu